E
COLLAPSE OF FTX.
>> Jesse: AOC WAS SUPPOSED TO
QUESTION MINI ALSO.
SHE SAID SHE SPENT ALL DAY DOING
HER HOMEWORK BONING UP ON CRYPTO
AND THEN THE TEST GOT CANCELED.
>> SOMETIMES SERVING IN CONGRESS
MEANS THAT YOU SPEND AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF TIME AND ENERGY
PREPARING A MAJOR LINE OF
QUESTIONING FOR, LET'S SAY, FOR
EXAMPLE, A CRYPTO BILLIONAIRE
THAT MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE MISUSED
A DEGREE OF FUNDS YOU A ARE
WORKING AND WORKING AND HAVING
BREAKTHROUGHS IN THE CASE AND
DEVELOPING A REALLY STRONG LINE
OF QUESTIONING AND THEN THE
NIGHT BEFORE YOUR HEARING YOUR
WITNESS GETS ARRESTED.
>> Jesse: THIS GUY WAS A FRAUD
FROM DAY ONE AND AOC WHO IS
SUPPOSED TO BE STREET SMART
WORKS AS A BARTENDER KNOWS THE
ROPES SHE DIDN'T CATCH ON UNTIL
MINI UNTIL THE MONEY WENT
MISSING?
WASHINGTON HAS EVERYTHING,
EXCEPT STREET SMARTS.
LOOK WHAT THEY DID TO THE
BORDER?
THEY SAID WALLS DON'T WORK, STOP
BUILDING THE WALL.
AND THE ENTIRE CONTINENT CAME
OVER.
PLUS, FENTANYL IS FIRE HOSING
INTO THE COUNTRY SO FAST IT
COULD KILL THE POPULATION NINE
TIMES OVER.
>> BIDEN JUST BUSY TRYING TO
APPEASE THE FRINGE OF HIS PARTY
INSTEAD OF ACTUALLY DOING
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
SAME THING WITH STICKY FINGER
SAMMY, REMEMBER THE BAG BURGLAR
YOU GOOGLE HIS NAME AND PORN
COMES UP.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION GOOGLED
HIS NAME AND SAID YOU'RE HIRED.
THE GUY STEALS WOMEN'S LUGGAGE
LIKE IT'S HIS JOB AND NOW HE IS
FIRED.
BUT THE WHITE HOUSE SAID THEY
NEVER HEARD OF SAMMY.
REALLY?
WELL, THAT'S' FUNNY BECAUSE
SAMMY IS BEST FRIENDS WITH MAYOR
PETE'S HUSBAND.
>> THIS IDEA OF INSPIRATION PORN
THAT YOUR MERE EXISTENCE IS
ENOUGH WHEN, SAM, YOU ARE OUT
THERE DOING CRITICAL WORK IN THE
COMMUNITY.
>> ONE OF MY FAVORITE STORIES IS
I WALKED IN TO DISNEY WORLD IN
MY STILETTOS, I LOVE -- I HAVE
52 PAIR OF HEELS, I LOVE
STILETTOS VERY IMPORTANT TO ME
AS EXPRESSING MYSELF, RIGHT?
I WALKED INTO DISNEY WITH THEM
AND LATER GET A MESSAGE FROM A
MOM BEING LIKE OH MY GOSH, MY
CHILD SAW YOU IN HEELS, IT WAS
SO WONDERFUL.
THE ONLY THING I'M GOING TO RED
FLAG IS YOU WALKED IN DISNEY
WORLD IN HEELS.
>> I DID.
>> I CAN'T DO DISNEY WORLD IN
TENNIS SHOES.
>> Jesse: I CAN'T.
MINI MADOFF, THE BORDER, STICKY
SAMMY, ALL EMBARRASSMENTS FOR
BIDEN.
BIDEN VETTED THE AFGHAN REFUGEES
CLINGING TO THE PLANES IN KABUL
BETTER THAN STICKY SAMMY, BUT
YOU HAVE DIFFERENT PRONOUNS, YOU
ARE HIRED.
TAKE WOMEN'S SPORTS.
BIDEN HAS DAUGHTERS.
HEY, HUNTER HAS DAUGHTERS,
KAMALA HAS A DAUGHTER.
DO THEY WANT THEIR DAUGHTERS
PLAYING SPORTS AGAINST DUDES?
NO THEY WANT YOUR DAUGHTERS
PLAYING SPORTS AGAINST DUDES.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED WHEN A
TRANS MAN PLAYED VOLLEYBALL
AGAINST A GIRL'S VOLLEYBALL
TEAM.
[SHOUTING]
[WHISTLE]
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHAT YOU CALL A
SPIKE OF DEATH.
WE ALL KNEW DEMOCRATS WERE DUMB
BUT NOW THIS IS GETTING
DANGEROUS.
THERE IS A REASON WE HAVE
DIFFERENT TEAMS, LOCKER ROOMS
AND PRISONS FOR MEN AND WOMEN.
THIS IS ALL COMMON SENSE.
IN MASSACHUSETTS, A PERSNICKETY
LIBRARIAN BANNED A CHRISTMAS
TREE BECAUSE THERE WAS ONE
ATHEIST IN A TOWN OF 100,000
CHRISTIANS.
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
AND ONCE "PRIMETIME" CALLED THEM
OUT, THEY BUCKLED AND SAID THEY
NEVER BANNED THE TREE, THEY WERE
JUST UNDER A DECORATION REVIEW.
TOTALLY BOGUS.
THEY GOT CAUGHT COLD AND NOW THE
TREE IS BACK UP AND THAT'S WHAT
MATTERS.
DEMOCRATS LIKE TO EXPERIMENT AND
WE'RE THE GUINEA PIGS.
LOOK AT THE DEFUND MOVEMENT
AFTER FLOYD GOT KILLED,
DEMOCRATS DECIDE ALL POLICE ARE
BAD, WE DON'T NEED THEM ANYMORE.
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN PRIVATE
SECURITY, SO THEY DIDN'T CARE
ABOUT ROLLING THE DICE WITH OUR
SAFETY.
BURLINGTON, VERMONT SLASHED
THEIR BUDGET AND KICKED OUT
DOZENS OF OFFICERS.
THEY TRIED REFUNDING POLICE BUT
COPS DIDN'T WANT TO WORK THERE
THEY DIDN'T TRUST THE
POLITICIANS.
AND THIS YEAR, BURLINGTON,
VERMONT HIT THEIR HIGHEST NUMBER
OF MURDERS SINCE THE 1960s.
IT'S OBVIOUS DEFUNDING POLICE
DOESN'T MAKE ANYBODY SAFER BUT
THEY HAVE NO COMMON SENSE.
PEOPLE WITH COMMON SENSE DON'T
SHUT DOWN DOMESTIC ENERGY
PRODUCTION WHILE RUSSIA PUTS
TROOPS ON THE UKRAINIAN BORDER.
LOOK AT TWITTER.
BLOWING UP IN THE DEMOCRATS'
FACE, TOO.
THEY NEVER COUNTED ON A GUY LIKE
MUSK BUYING TWITTER AND THEN
AIRING OUT THE DIRT.
WE ALWAYS HAD AN IDEA HOW
DEMOCRATS USED TWITTER AGAINST
US BUT NOW WE KNOW TWITTER
WASN'T A PRIVATE COMPANY.
IT WAS A DEMOCRAT DONOR.
IT WASN'T A PRIVATE COMPANY, IT
WAS AN FBI SUBCONTRACTOR.
TEAMING WITH FEDS, THIRSTY TO
STIFLE US.
AND THIS IS TOTALLY BLOWN UP,
BUT THE MEDIA DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
JUST LIKE BIDEN DOESN'T WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE BORDER.
BECAUSE WE ARE DEALING WITH
CHILDREN.
EXCEPT THESE CHILDREN ARE POWER.
IT'S LIKE IF YOU PUT YOUR
10-YEAR-OLD IN CHARGE OF THE
FAMILY FOR A DAY FOR FOUR YEARS.
IT'S A CRISISSER HOUR.
SAME THING WITH THE DEMOCRATS.
PONZI SCHEME, THE BORDER CRISIS,
TO CRIME WAVE.
WE GET STUCK WITH THE BILL, THE
TOE TAGS, THE BAD REPS.
WE GET C